this street in bowling green kentucky
once rang with the sounds of children
playing young families lived here but
then on friday the tornado came and some
neighbors sheltered together they
decided to
get in the first house
together
and unfortunately house was
just demolished to the ground
eleven people died here eight of them
were children
ben ceramovic is a family friend
i don't know what to say man
[Music]
it just
it's hard when somebody's gone and
you're shocked you know
what happened to this world
as recovery workers sift through the
debris left in six states all struck by
last week's super storm leaving this
landscape of devastation authorities
fear the final death toll will be
staggering
nine-year-old aniston rackley climbed
into a bathtub with her younger sisters
and her doll this photo taken by their
mother 15 minutes before the tornado hit
anniston was killed her sister survived
one recounting to nurses which she'd
endured
she said yes i was flying around in the
tornado
and i prayed to jesus
to take care of me
and he spit me out and the tornado spit
me out into the mud
president joe biden comforted stricken
families and toured the disaster area
wednesday i intend to do whatever it
takes as long as it takes as long as it
takes to support your state
your local leaders and as you recover
and rebuild because you will recover and
you will rebuild
jared thompson and his family survive by
hunkering in their basement you gotta
have a positive attitude
life can't be replaced but you probably
can
you can rebuild but it might take a
while which we have family friends and
other
people in the community that are
stepping up that are assisting us with
thousands of homes wiped away the
rebuilding process will be long and
difficult the healing even harder
heidi joe castro al jazeera mayfield
kentucky